The story I'm telling you is…
what I, Rohan Kishibe, heard
with myown ears.
It was a horrifying incident.
Do you know what a "confessional" is?
Every Italian church has one of those.
It has two wooden boxes
that look like telephone booths.
The parish priest gets
in the one with the curtains,
and the parishioner goes in the otherbox.
There's a little window
between the twoboxes,
and voices can go
through the window,but…
the priest and parishioner
cannot see each other.
The window allows the parishioner
to confess their "sins"
with their privacy securely protected.
You see, you can't keep a secret
hidden deep in your heart for years.
The graver the secret is,
the greaterthe suffering of the heart.
A confessional is a place
to purge a soulof its sins.
It was created
by the wisdom of people in the past.
It's not allowed, but I took some photos
when the priest wasn't around
and looked closely at the design
and materials of the carvings.
And just for an experience,
I thought it wouldn't be a bad idea
if I could confess to a priest myself.
So I went in the box.
The actual experience
would bring reality into my work, you see.
Huh?
Father, I've come to make a confession.
I have committed a great sin.
Wha…
I can't stand it anymore.
I've got to tell you, Father.
I can't sleep
without making a confession.
I swear it!
At that time, I didn't know the box
with the curtains was for the priest.
This man mistook me for the priest.
But…
wasn't this a stroke of luck?
What's his "great sin"?
I might as well
listen through to theend.
A real experience
brings reality into my work.
It doesn't matter
who listens to his confession.
After all, it's the thought
that he confessed to the priest
that matters for this man.
Father, is there anything wrong?